only on cbs news the head of u.s
intelligence is commenting on whether
american spy agencies have found
evidence of foreign entities changing
votes and thereby altering the recent
election
it is a key claim by president trump's
legal team in its attempts
to overturn the results senior
investigative correspondent catherine
harris spoke exclusively with john
ratcliffe
in his first network interview as
director of national intelligence
does the intelligence show that any
foreign adversary or criminal group had
the ability
to change the vote results not that
we've been able to determine now
at this point in time we're still
analyzing all of the intelligence
tremendous voter fraud and
irregularities when the president
gives a video on voter fraud allegations
is that intelligence coming from you
well i can't tell you the specific
information that i give the president
but voter fraud is not an issue for the
intelligence community per se
that's a domestic law enforcement issue
does the intelligence show that foreign
adversaries
are amplifying the voter fraud
allegations
uh they are who's doing that i can't
tell you
but they are yes and what's their
objective to undermine public confidence
in
our democratic processes
as the government prepares for a new
administration in january
radcliff says china is now the nation's
most pressing national security threat
from efforts to steal covet vaccine
research to ripping off
the us economy china intends to dominate
the world
economically militarily and
technologically they intend to be the
world's superpower
how many americans and billions of
dollars have been lost to the chinese
u.s government estimates about 500
billion dollars a year which would
impact every
american household four to six thousand
dollars a year as a result of what china
is doing on the economic espionage front
what does the intelligence show
about foreign efforts to steal
covid 19 vaccine research china
has been attempting to access our
research
into covid19 so the pandemic that was
created by china's
actions they've attempted to steal our
research
has it been aggressive in the last year
everything that china does is aggressive
what is your message on china to the
biden team
they're our greatest adversary it's the
greatest threat that this country has
faced
since world war ii director radcliffe
said the delayed transition has not put
the biden team at a disadvantage
president-elect biden and vice
president-elect harris are now receiving
the same highly classified information
as president trump reckless says he
plans to release a fuller report on
foreign election interference
in january anthony catherine thank you